STEV WELMEACK.
MOREEARS OF NCY LOSI
HELPG TH RLECTNIDTE HERHO S I FT
FORPIRINOTHING SS IAT
AKE AN OUR DOCRA AND
THISS WHI NEY R
RESPECTFLY SK YO
AND OPLE ASKE TH MOS
IMRTANISES FING E
NGRE I ALWAYSAY E SA
[LGHTESTE: IHINKHE COULD EVE
IS ARE MEF HEI.C.
CRMS -.
AN I.C.ECREASHOPNISIN
CHOO?NUT WCH D HE
ECK ISUT CSTANY
OMOTG THE SA BRAF
I.E. CRE WHYS TH?
TURNS OUHE FOUERS AI DEEP DE A I
FOTHE MOCRS SUPPORNGDE
BIDEN EN NINAT F
PRIDEN AND I T 201
JOEY BEOT ISLWAYABOUTH
POTICS EVEWITH I.E.
CRM.
MAYB JY BE WOU BE  A
TH'S W WE OULD HAVMAY
ECTE[LGHTE
E ISIGHT IF U NOCE I
THIDEO BECAU OF MAN
SHE  ALSOORRE WHEN IS
ABOUT E CHDRENT ITHDEMOATS WANTL
UR CHIREN ITS LIHE
TWILHT ZE ISODWITH TRTIA I WAS O
INK HE CTEXT A THE
TH WANTOONTR YOUCHDRENUT THE BDS
EVYONEHEY SAY JOE BEN IINLVEDN E
IS T B T INFLATI ISTRSITOND T S
BULO IN E VACCINWILL
KEEPOU FM SPADG THVIS OFOURSEVES
NE
THE OGM TS IALL THEYN
OW HOW T DO TYIVE
BLATTLY.
THEIGGETHE E E MOEXTINGT ISND TA
STEVE: B DIDT PESI
RSEL SAY THAURING AEW
SSIOAND THE CHAENGEHE
ORGANIZI AGAST HER
AGN? SHEROMISED T TO RUN
>> TT WA THE IMPLICAON
PROGRESSES HE TBEONESTH THEWEREP
ONS AND THETO SPRISUS
TH T FT TH THE AT SO  LEA THEY I
SHS THE COEMPTHAT E
S FOTHPEOP OF N
ANCIO AND FO EVEAMICANHAT SHE OS
THE SIDER TRING E'S NE
HORRIBL JOB TOUNT IONIRE ANDHEE
DON'T RE A THAIS THE
DIEREN THERE HE BESURISEIN PITSE
T AOT OGOOD PEOE HE
FT CIFORNIA  THE ARE
FEWEPEOP TRE T REB ITHK OFRIC NA
NEWB GOTIM KICKEOUT
FICE.
SO SHEIGHTE FEIN PREY
MFORBLE ERE IS NHING
FT BESES WHAT  INSE
R FRZER D E ISINE
WITHHAT.
DO BTEMAYBJENN BE WOU
[LAUTE
AT W GRE.
OD TO SE WAS AAYSEOPL